Nur weil da jetzt vier Wochen die Leute
hinkommen und Fußball spielen, wird
auf einmal jetzt nicht das Kafala
System fallen und alteingesessene Kataris werden
sagen "Ach Mensch, jetzt war ja
die FIFA da, die kommen aus der Schweiz.
Tolle Leute, wir revolutionieren mal
unsere ganze Gesellschaft, unsere ganze
Kultur." Das wird ja nicht
passieren. 13 Fragen, hier kommt die erste: Sollte
die deutsche Nationalmannschaft die WM
in Katar boykottieren? Ja oder nein?
Wenn ihr sagt Ja, angesichts der Menschenrechtsverletzungen
ist ein Boykott
mehr als angebracht, dann bitte auf die grüne
Seite gehen. Und wenn ihr sagt Nein,
ein Boykott könnte sogar
eventuell mehr schaden als helfen, dann bitte
auf die gelbe Seite gehen. Vielen
Dank, jetzt wissen wir, wo ihr steht, aber
wo steht ihr eigentlich? In knapp
einem Jahr geht sie los,
die Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft 2022
in Katar, mitten im deutschen Winter.
Und die deutsche Nationalelf hat sich
ja längst qualifiziert. Die Frage ist: Sollte
sie auch teilnehmen? Denn schon bei der Vergabe
vor rund zehn Jahren gab es ja
heftige Korruptionsvorwürfe und weitere
Kritik, Katar halte sich nicht
an fundamentale Menschenrechte. Also
es geht um die Benachteiligung von Frauen,
die Unterdrückung von Schwulen und Lesben
und auch die moderne Sklaverei auf den WM
Baustellen. Grund genug, sagen die einen,
für einen Boykott als klares Zeichen
gegen diese Menschenrechtsverletzungen.
Moment, so einfach ist es nicht, sagen
die anderen. Ein Boykott könnte
eventuell sogar mehr schaden als helfen. Bei 13
Fragen geht es ja um den Kompromiss.
Es wird heute spannend zu sehen sein,
ob diese beiden Parteien
aufeinander zugehen können und wie ein Kompromiss
überhaupt aussehen könnte. Das werden
wir am Ende der Folge sehen. Jetzt erst mal
die Frage an euch: Wie würdet ihr euch
entscheiden? Auf die grüne Seite gehen
und sagen, ein Boykott ist jetzt
dringend notwendig oder auf die gelbe: lieber
nicht, das könnte eventuell sogar
schaden. Schreibt es mir gerne in die Kommentare
und begründet gerne eure Meinung.
Ganz kurz zu den Regeln: Wenn ihr im Laufe
der folgenden Diskussion der Gegenseite
zustimmt, dann geht gerne einen Schritt
auf sie zu auf dem Feld. Wenn ihr sagt
"Eigentlich finde ich deine Meinung sogar
plausibel, aber das, was du jetzt
gerade erzählst, ist totaler Quatsch", dann könnt
ihr auch gerne einen Schritt
zurückgehen. Mein Ziel ist es, am Ende der Folge
möglichst viele von euch hier in diesem sogenannten
Kompromissfeld wiederzufinden.
Also wir suchen ja eine Lösung und wollen
den Konflikt nicht noch weiter verhärten.
13 Fragen. Hier kommt jetzt Frage
Nummer zwei und die geht an Neven. Als ehemaliger
Profi warst du ja sogar schon
mal bei einer Weltmeisterschaft. 2010,
Südafrika glaube ich? Richtig. Gar
nicht so unerfolgreich, kann man sagen. Wenn du
jetzt heute noch mal 20 oder Anfang
20 wärst und gefragt werden würdest "Kommst
du mit nach Katar?", würdest du ja oder nein
sagen? Kommt drauf an, welches Wissen
ich habe und welche Haltung ich habe.
Mit Erfahrungen, die ich jetzt habe, würde
ich das nicht tun. Mit der Erfahrung,
die ich damals hatte, glaube ich würde
ich das tun. Und deshalb glaube ich auch,
es ist verantwortlich für die Spieler,
die schon mehr Lebenserfahrung haben,
auch zu helfen, so eine Entscheidung vielleicht
mal mitzutragen. Aber
grundsätzlich finde ich es schwer, dass jetzt alle
Mannschaften oder auch vor allem
die großen Mannschaften absagen,
weil wir sprechen ja auch nur über die Menschenrechtsverletzungen,
weil es die WM
gibt. Und auch nur deshalb ist der aktuelle
Druck auch da. Ein Boykott würde
nicht nur zu nichts führen, sondern er würde
schaden. Wir haben eine Brücke,
die der Sport ist, um auch unter Menschengruppen
untereinander
zusammenzukommen und den Sport an sich
zu feiern und das auch als verbindendes
Element zu nutzen. Und diese Brücke
sollten wir unbedingt nutzen. Also glaubst
du, ein Boykott wäre eher
kontraproduktiv in Sachen Menschenrechte? Es würde nicht
dazu führen, dass die Menschenrechte,
die wir erhoffen, die sich dort etablieren,
dass diese tatsächlich auch realisiert
werden. Ich denke, es würde schaden. Also,
Neven sagt, die Menschenrechtsverletzungen
müssen an die Öffentlichkeit
und sie kriegen durch eine WM auch eine große
Öffentlichkeit. Und ein Boykott wäre
eher kontraproduktiv.
Könnt ihr das nachvollziehen?
Also ich kann die Argumente
absolut nachvollziehen. Natürlich, mit einem
Spotlight werden auch diese Themen
mal aufgearbeitet, die ansonsten überhaupt
nicht bei uns auf dem Radar
erscheinen. Aber ob die Konsequenz dann wirklich
die ist, dass wir bessere
Menschenrechtsverhältnisse in Katar
-wirklich haben, das bezweifle ich.
-Deswegen bist du auch nicht nach vorne.
Genau deswegen habe ich mich nicht
bewegt. Ich war kurz davor, aber dann dachte ich,
nein, es passt einfach nicht.
Ich persönlich als Frau sehe natürlich
auch die WM in Katar auch noch mit besonderen
Augen. Frauenrechte spielen da,
neben anderen Grundrechten, keine
Rolle. Und auch queer lebende Menschen werden
dort ja, wie soll ich sagen,
mit Füßen getreten.
Du bist ja nun selber
leidenschaftlicher Fußballfan, aber auch aus- durchaus
auch aus persönlichen Gründen. Willst
du diese WM einfach generell ablehnen? Warum,
-erklär mal?
-Ja, ich bin ein Fußballfan und ich bin
auch nicht islamfeindlich und habe
da auch keine Vorbehalte. Aber ich habe
tatsächlich schon ein Problem damit,
dass wir da in einer absoluten Monarchie
zu Hause sind, wo dieser Fußball
ausgetragen wird und darüber hinaus,
du hast es in der Moderation ja auch schon
zusammengefasst, die Menschen werden
versklavt, Frauen sind Leibeigene
ihrer Männer. Das kann ich einfach nicht
mittragen und möchte es auch nicht
mitgehen. Ich bin auch eine Frau,
die in diesem Land eigentlich gar
nicht gut leben könnte. Und ich könnte
auch schon gar nicht als queer lebend
dort wirklich zu Hause sein. Und ich sehe halt
auch keine Beweisführung, dass in der Vergangenheit
ein großes Sportereignis
wirklich die Folge hatte, dass sich
da grundsätzlich etwas verändert hat.
Wie geht es euch? Geht den Schritt
auf sie zu? Ich meine, man muss ja ganz klar
sagen, was du gerade gesagt hast: Frau,
queer lebend, nach der WM würde Felicia ja
im Knast landen. Wahrscheinlich. Also
ich würde zu vielem zustimmen. Das ist klar,
dass dort es keine freie
Zivilgesellschaft gibt, keine Gewerkschaften. Es gibt keine
freien Wahlen. Es ist eine Erbmonarchie,
aber ich finde, wir sollten uns jetzt,
ein Jahr vor der WM, ein bisschen
mehr auf die auf die Realität zubewegen.
In der Geschichte des Sports haben nur ganz,
ganz wenige Boykotte etwas gebracht.
Mit einem autoritären Regime wie in Katar
muss man glaub ich diplomatischer
sprechen, damit man positive Effekte
bekommt. Wer verdient denn an dieser WM
Geld? Das sind große deutsche
Konzerne, die dort eine Straßenbahn bauen, die dort
viele Trikots verkaufen wollen,
die dort Maschinen herstellen. Wenn man
dieses Turnier boykottiert, dann
müsste man die gesamte globalisierte Wirtschaft
und die gesamt globalisierten Fußball
boykottieren. Und deswegen ist es leicht,
auf Katar draufzuhauen. Aber wir, auch als kritische
Fußballfans, gehören zu einem
Fußballsystem, in dem Menschen zu Schaden
kommen. Also sollte man den Fußball
komplett boykottieren. Aber ist
nicht Katar jetzt mal wirklich einer zu viel?
Also ja, Kommerzialisierung im Fußball,
Moral und Ethik wird nicht so groß
geschrieben, es geht ums Geld
verdienen und so weiter. Aber bei Katar ist doch
alles sowas von offensichtlich, dass ein Boykott
doch irgendwie auch ein Zeichen
Richtung FIFA wäre unter dem Motto,
ey, bis hierhin und nicht weiter und es gibt
auch Grenzen. Als Fußballfan möchte
ich einfach kein Eröffnungsspiel an einem
Novembertag sehen und eine WM im Winter
erleben. Und als politischer Mensch möchte
ich nicht, dass die deutsche
Nationalmannschaft bzw. deutsche Spieler
Teil eines so großen inszenierten
politischen Zirkus sind und ein Regime
damit Legitimation erteilen, durch
die Teilnahme an der WM. Wie weit will man
denn dieses ganze Spiel noch treiben,
wenn jetzt schon darüber nachgedacht wird,
wir machen eine WM alle
zwei Jahre? Also es sind ja nicht
nur die Menschenrechtssituationen in Katar,
die man irgendwie berücksichtigen
muss, sondern auch die Kommerzialisierung
im Fußball. Und wo geht das alles hin
-und wer wird überhaupt gefragt?
-Ich glaube, dass das genau der
entscheidende Punkt ist. Ich glaube,
die Frage des Boykotts ist vor allen Dingen
dem Fakt geschuldet, dass viele
Versprechen und viele Gesetze die es ja
gibt, die es ja unbestritten gibt,
dass die aber nicht eingehalten werden
und dass gerade die Öffentlichkeit
oder auch die Fußball interessierte
Öffentlichkeit frustriert ist und immer
wieder sieht, die Leute leiden trotzdem
weiter. Es gab viele Versprechen von der FIFA,
aber auch von der katarischen
Regierung. Die wurden alle nicht
eingehalten. Wir wissen, es gibt weitere
Menschenrechtsverletzungen und ich glaube,
dass die Boykottdiskussion Druck erhöhen
wird und weiter einen
großen Fokus auf dieses Thema lenkt.
Aber das ist doch eine spannende Frage.
Ab welchem Grad Menschenrechtsverletzung ist
ein Boykott gerechtfertigt und wann nicht?
Also wir hatten ja Brasilien,
Südafrika lief auch schon vieles
nicht besonders gut, auch in Sachen
Menschenrechte. Warum ist dann Katar
jetzt der Punkt, wo du zum Beispiel sagst:
Boykott jetzt? Ich glaube, es geht
gar nicht darum, dass jetzt Leute sagen,
dort soll keine WM stattfinden.
Dort kann meiner Meinung nach sehr wohl
eine Fußball-WM stattfinden.
Aber diese ganzen Begleitumstände,
die wir in den letzten elf Jahren
sehen, die führen dazu, dass auf Deutsch gesagt,
die Fußballfans die Schnauze voll
haben und sagen: Bis hierhin und nicht weiter.
Bis hierhin und nicht weiter.
Kannst du nachvollziehen, Sebastian? Ich kann
es zum Teil nachvollziehen. Ich glaube,
dass sich die Diskussion jetzt an Katar so
hochgeschaukelt hat, aus ganz vielen
Gründen. Benjamin, du hast einige davon
angesprochen. Ich glaube aber, dass ein Boykott
eben nicht dazu führen würde,
dass diese Diskussion weitergeführt
wird. Ich glaube, ein Boykott ändert nichts.
Ein Boykott von einzelnen Ländern
trägt nur dazu bei, dass die Situation sich
verschärft. Nicht alles in Katar hat
sich verbessert, aber es gibt Fortschritte
und diese sind vor allen Dingen aus Druck
erfolgt. Und deswegen glaube ich,
dass die Aufmerksamkeit nur dann
erfolgen kann, wenn man das ganze Thema breit
anlegt. Und dazu gehört eben auch,
Aktivität in Katar und Präsenz in Katar
zu zeigen. Wir sprechen einmal über
die Situation der Menschenrechte. Da bin
ich der Meinung, dass Migration nicht
nur in Katar stattfindet, sondern Migration
quasi nach Katar führt, aber ja auch schon
in Pakistan, in Bangladesch, in vielen,
vielen anderen Ländern stattfindet, wo die Situation
für die Menschen so katastrophal
ist, wirtschaftlich und gesellschaftlich,
dass sie quasi das Land verlassen müssen.
Sie werden auf der Reise dahin von oftmals
Kriminellen Rekrutierungsagenturen
ausgebeutet, müssen enorme Summen
bezahlen und landen dann in Katar, wo sozusagen
dann die Ausnutzung und die Ausbeutung
in gewisser Art und Weise weitergeht.
Und deswegen glaube ich, eine Austragung
der WM, verbunden mit Maßnahmen,
die vom Sport, von der Politik, von NGOs,
von der internationalen Gemeinschaft
diese Migrationsstrukturen kritisieren,
in der Gesamtheit, die macht glaube ich Sinn.
Das Problem ist nicht Katar als Land.
Das Problem ist die FIFA. Das Problem ist
die Institution der FIFA, die in den letzten
Jahren bei vielen WM eben korrupt
vergeben hat, wo Korruption eine große
Rolle spielt. Es gibt viele Menschen
in der Region, die sich freuen, dass diese WM
auch mal in ihrer Region stattfindet
und nicht nur in Südamerika, Europa
oder Asien. Diese Leute haben eine gewisse
Berechtigung auch, denen sollte man
zumindest zuhören. Und von daher glaube
ich, sind das die Dinge, über die wir sprechen
sollten. So, jetzt Hubi, du bist
ja so halb gerade nach vorne
gegangen. Halb, so ein bisschen, ja. Bleiben
wir doch mal beim letzten Punkt
vielleicht. Ich würde jetzt einfach
den Punkt, den Menschen in der Region
würdest du die Fußball-WM madig machen.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht,
wie die Katarer das selber sehen. Es gibt ja
auch nicht so viele. Gibt es ja glaub
ich nur 200 Tausend, 300 Tausend. Der Rest
sind ja alles Gastarbeiter. Geht ja
auch nicht nur- es geht um die Region. Es geht
sozusagen um die arabische Welt, auch um die islamische
Welt. Und quasi Katar hat
eben aus vielen Gründen, über die wir schon
gesprochen haben, die auch recht
problematisch sind, die Möglichkeiten,
so eine WM auszurichten, die halt Ägypten,
Tunesien oder Jordanien nicht hat,
aber ich wollte dich nicht unterbrechen,
entschuldige. Nee, das ist ja alles
gut. Klar, da freuen sich dann wahrscheinlich
auch ein paar Leute. Aber ich meine,
200 Milliarden Euro kostet dieses ganze
Projekt, glaube ich. Und da muss
man sich ein bisschen die Frage
der Verhältnismäßigkeit stellen.
Also es ist 2021. Wir reden über Ressourcen,
Klimawandel und so weiter. Und dann
stellt man da mitten in die Wüste das da alles
hin für 200 Milliarden Euro auf der Basis
einer korrupten Vergabe in ein Land,
wo die Fußballkultur quasi nicht
existiert. Damit wir so einen Eiertanz
machen, damit wir im Winter, damit das auf jeden
Fall da stattfinden kann, im Winter
auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt die WM
gucken. Also das ist doch ein bisschen viel des
Guten. So, jetzt sind alle drei
nach hinten gegangen. Warum? Zum einen,
weil wir Katar nicht aus den falschen
Gründen kritisieren sollten.
Das Winterargument ist kein Argument,
weil überall ist es mal warm, ist es mal kalt
und ich finde, wir sollten auch mehr
auf die Argumente und die Motivation von Katar
schauen. Katar ist ein sehr wohlhabender
Staat. Die brauchen unsere Zuneigung
eigentlich nicht. Warum will Katar,
die WM? Weil sie lange unter der Bedrohung
von Saudi-Arabien standen, weil sie Angst
vor einem Krieg haben, vor einer Invasion.
Deswegen nutzen wir die Nähe zu westlichen
Partnern, Wissenschaft, Fußball,
Politik eben auch als Sicherheitspolitik,
die Frage ist, ob wir daran mitmachen
sollen. Dennoch, die UN hat mehr
als 200 Mitglieder, die FIFA hat noch mehr
Mitglieder. Und die besteht eben nicht
nur aus europäischen Demokratien Deutschland,
Skandinavien. Wenn ihr keine WM mehr
haben wollt in China, in der in der arabischen
Welt, müsst ihr ein Argument
haben, wie ihr die Staaten in Nordamerika,
in Lateinamerika, in Afrika, die Fans
dort zu motivieren, dagegen zu stimmen.
Diese Debatte wird in Westeuropa
geführt und sie wird wahrscheinlich nicht mal
in Spanien geführt, sondern nur in Deutschland
und in Großbritannien.
Das reicht nicht, um die FIFA zu revolutionieren.
Benjamin hast du nicht
-überzeugt. Warum nicht?
-Ich würde noch mal ganz gern einen Schritt
zurückgehen, wenn wir uns noch
mal die Vergabekriterien anschauen.
Menschenrechte haben damals überhaupt
keine Rolle gespielt und für mich spielt
die Verantwortung der FIFA eine sehr,
sehr große Rolle. Natürlich kann man oder muss
man auch Katar kritisieren, aber man
muss eben an die Strukturen ran. Man muss
schauen, warum spielt Geld so eine große
Rolle? Und das ist für mich auch eine ganz
entscheidende Frage: Welche
Verantwortung trägt die FIFA und wird wird die FIFA
dieser Verantwortung
gerecht? Aus meiner Sicht absolut nicht.
Vollkommen klar. Die FIFA Diskussion
und überhaupt der Profifußball oder überhaupt
Profisport in Gänze, das ist
sicherlich ein Thema, aber lasst uns doch mal
versuchen, heute ein bisschen
realpolitisch zu bleiben und zu gucken,
Boykott ja oder nein? Was machen wir jetzt?
Hilft das jetzt konkret? Wir reden
jetzt über in einem Jahr. Das ist
relativ kurzfristig. Und wenn jetzt
ein Boykottaufruf kommt, ist ja die Frage:
Unterstützen wir ihn oder unterstützen
wir ihn nicht? Und hier war das Argument:
Mit eurem Boykott, mit eurem sage
ich jetzt mal, mit eurem Boykott
helft ihr den Menschen unter dem Thema
Menschenrechte eben nicht weiter,
sondern im Gegenteil, ihr torpediert
-sie vielleicht sogar. Was antwortest du?
-Ich glaube, dass wenn es einzelne Profis
gibt, die sagen, da mache ich nicht
mit, ist das meiner Meinung nach das maximale
Zeichen, was wir erwarten können.
Ich glaube wie gesagt nicht, dass große
Fußballnationen nicht hinfahren. Ich glaube
aber sehr wohl, dass Profis das,
was ja Neven auch gerade gesagt
hat, mit der Erfahrung die er jetzt hat,
als erfahrener, als gestandener
Spieler kann ich mir sehr wohl vorstellen,
dass Spieler sagen, wir fahren dort
nicht hin und ich glaube, dass das ein sehr,
-sehr wichtiges Zeichen wäre.
-Felicia, wir hatten gerade das Thema
gehabt. Menschenrechte verteidigen
geht mit Boykott eventuell schlechter, war
das Argument von dieser Seite. Du
stimmst dem nicht zu? Warum nicht? Es ist doch
irgendwie plausibel, dass man
sagt, hey, da ist so viel Spotlight drauf,
jetzt können wir da wirklich die gesamte
Weltöffentlichkeit mal draufsetzen.
Und am Ende hilft es den Menschen
vor Ort vielleicht tatsächlich mehr.
Ich habe vorher angebracht, das ist
eine absolute Monarchie. Es ist ja
auch ein Land, das sich vom Göttlichen
getragen fühlt. Die Gesetzgebung ist Gott
gemacht. Ein Staat ist nie Gott
gemacht. Auch ein Königreich ist nicht göttlich.
Also wir haben ja da wirklich
einen Grundkonflikt, den wir hier austragen
müssen für die Werte, die wir stehen.
Und natürlich, wir hatten auch eine WM
in Russland. Wir wissen alle, wie Vergaben
funktionieren. Die folgen nicht
nur Völkerverständigung, das ist ja
total naiv, sondern das geht um ein ganz anderes
Spiel. Um Geld, meistens. Meistens um Geld,
um sehr viel Geld. Und das ist doch
das ganze Leitmotiv. Und von dem bin
ich es eben auch leid. Und diese Systeme
werden ja vor allen Dingen von Männern
getragen, ob in Katar oder bei der FIFA.
Und das ist ehrlich gesagt der Punkt,
wo ich wirklich sage, ich habe die Schnauze
voll und sehe da wirklich- Ich habe
gar keine Lust, ein großes Turnier
zu boykottieren, junge Menschen von ihrem
sportlichen Erfolg abzuhalten. Aber
wie soll dieses Rad denn irgendwann
mal gestoppt werden? Ich habe keine Idee,
wenn da nicht irgendwann- wir kennen
alle Neuanfänge- erst mal muss da irgendwie
grundlegend mal ein Stoppschild
rein. Und wenn es eben ein Boykott ist,
der da am Ende helfen kann, dass wir eine Neuordnung
finden, dann bitte schön.
Jetzt war Neven die ganze Zeit in der Mitte
und das Stoppschild hat dich
nach hinten getrieben. Warum? Das klingt
doch total plausibel. Ja, das klingt total
plausibel. Ich finde aber auf der anderen
Seite, wir haben in unserer Menschheit
auch ein paar schöne Dinge
geschaffen. Kultur ist eine davon. Und vor allem,
wenn wir auch auf kultureller Ebene
eine Basis haben, auf der wir uns austauschen.
Nicht nur die Kataris an sich, sondern die WM
an sich, wo viele Nationen vertreten
werden. Die besten finden sich dann
vor Ort und haben einen Wettbewerb, der dann
von den Fans und den Nationen mit auch getragen,
gefeiert und erlebt wird.
Das ist ein wunderschönes Ereignis
für die Menschheit. Ich würde das nicht
wegschaffen, weil mir der eine Aspekt
oder der ein Aspekt, die sicherlich
auch wichtig sind, also wir sollten
die weiter behalten. Ich glaube, Benjamin hat
das sehr gut gesagt. Wir sollten
sehr, sehr gezielt mit den Maßnahmen umgehen,
nicht einfach wegschaffen und dann
hoffen, dass irgendwas sich verändert,
sondern tatsächlich sehr gezielt da, wo es nötig
ist, da auch die Punkte draufsetzen.
Wir haben schon darüber gesprochen,
in Katar, die Menschenrechtsverletzungen
sollten wir nicht klein machen, ganz
im Gegenteil, wir sollten sie groß machen
und auch groß halten, weil es sind
Menschen gestorben. Amnesty hat jetzt
auch vor ein paar Tagen darüber
berichtet, dass genau diese politischen Maßnahmen,
über die du sprichst, die nicht
implementiert wurden. Zumindest gab
es politische Maßnahmen und in diesem Fall
müssen wir natürlich auch zur Kenntnis
nehmen, die kamen nicht durch eine soziale
Revolution, wo die Leute das eingefordert
haben, sondern in diesem Fall
müssen wir leider annehmen, es gab erst mal
den politischen Wandel und hoffentlich
kommt dann auch der soziale Wandel.
Gleichzeitig können wir auch den sozialen
Wandel für Menschenrechte darin
etablieren, indem wir den Kontakt
und auch den Respekt füreinander aufbauen.
Und da rede ich nicht über
füreinander, von Politik zu Politik unbedingt,
sondern auch zwischenmenschlich. Und da sehe
ich es als falschen Punkt. Jetzt
das erste Mal, dass im Nahen
Osten eine WM ausgetragen wird, genau
es zu diesem Zeitpunkt zu machen. Und da gebe
ich euch auch völlig recht. Fußball,
das ist eine ganz andere Debatte.
Fußball verliert den Anker und es geht nur noch
um Geld. Newcastle wurde vor kurzem
aufgebaut. Ich bin da nicht dafür, ganz
im Gegenteil. Und trotzdem ist Hubi
nach Nevens Aussage so leicht nach vorne
gegangen. Er hat, Neven, hat ja
auch argumentiert, es hilft im Zweifel
der Menschenrechtslage sogar mehr,
wenn da wirklich was passiert und endlich mal
dieses zarte Pflänzchen so ein bisschen
gegossen wird, wenn ich dich richtig
verstanden habe. Wie erklärst du dir
das? Ich bin nach vorne gegangen, weil Neven
sagte, man musste sehr gezielt
gucken, was man da macht. Ich glaube auch,
dass es illusorisch ist, dass ganze
Verbände jetzt das boykottieren werden,
aber, wie Benjamin auch sagte, ein Einzelner
kann schon sehr viel bewegen,
wenn ein großer Spieler oder ein Spieler
einer großen Nation sagt, ich gehe
da nicht hin. Und er hat vielleicht
einen schlauen Berater, der sagt: "Pass mal auf,
gehen in dieses und jenes Medienformat
und dann thematisieren wir das alles mal,
warum gehst du dann nicht hin? Wir ziehen
das über deine Biographie und über
deine Entscheidung. Und du setzt
jetzt quasi durch deine Entscheidung,
zu boykottieren, als einzelner
den Spotlight auf Qatar", dann könnte
das glaube ich sehr viel bewegen
und ein ganz anderes Spotlight setzen,
als wenn man die Normalität bedient
und alles so macht wie FIFA und Katar sich
das so vorgestellt haben. Und wie gesagt,
das ist doch eine sehr künstliche
Veranstaltung. Das hat man ja
auch in Brasilien gesehen. Das hat man
in Südafrika gesehen, dass diese FIFA
Zonen entstehen, dass da etwas hingestellt
wird für vier Wochen, und dann sind wir wieder
weg und wir hinterlassen Brachland.
Dadurch wird sich nichts ändern. Und,
was ich auch noch sagen wollte, man darf
glaube ich nicht zu naiv sein,
welchen bekehrenden Charakter so eine Fußball-WM
haben kann. Also nur weil da jetzt
vier Wochen die Leute hinkommen und Fußball
spielen, wird auf einmal nicht das Kafala
System fallen und alteingesessene Kataris
werden sagen "Ach Mensch, jetzt war
ja die FIFA da, die kommen aus der Schweiz.
Tolle Leute, wir revolutionieren mal
unsere ganze, unsere ganze Gesellschaft,
unsere ganze Kultur." Das wird ja nicht
passieren. Die MenschenrechtsaktivistInnen
von Amnesty International und Human
Rights Watch sagen: Mag ja alles sein, dass du
recht hast, aber trotzdem sind wir gegen einen
Boykott, weil wir glauben,
dass dieses zarte Pflänzchen so
besser gegossen werden kann. Was antwortest du
denen? Ich weiß, dass das illusorisch
ist. Unabhängig davon. Der DFB duckt sich ja
in der ganzen Sache ziemlich weg. Vom DFB
ist glaube ich so ziemlich gar nichts
zu erwarten. Dementsprechend wird
das nicht passieren. In einer idealen Welt,
wenn jetzt ein Verband wie der DFB
sagt: Wir boykottieren das und machen uns mal
Gedanken mit den Weltklassespieler,
die wir haben, die weltweit bekannt sind,
die Fokus auf Katar lenken. Ich glaube,
dann würde man sehr viel mehr
Öffentlichkeit herstellen, als es überhaupt
jemals möglich wäre, wenn du
dahin fährst und spielst. So,
Sebastian ist die ganze Zeit am hin und her laufen,
habe ich gesehen, du warst mal in der Mitte,
dann bist du wieder zurückgelaufen.
Ich bin vor allem deswegen zurückgegangen,
weil das religiöse Argument kam.
Darauf möchte ich jetzt aber
weniger eingehen, sondern ich möchte nur kurz
was zum Kafala System sagen. Du
hast natürlich grundsätzlich recht. Es ist
ein System, was es schon seit
Generationen nicht nur in den Golfstaaten,
sondern in der gesamten arabischen
Welt gibt. Es beruht eher auf Gewohnheitsrecht
als auf kodifiziertem Recht. Das ist
auch das Problem, dass zum Beispiel
im häuslichen Bereich die Regelungen
einfach nicht verschärft werden können,
meistens, weil das tatsächlich nicht
der Autorität des Staates oftmals obliegt,
sondern demjenigen, der im häuslichen
Bereich auch das Sagen hat und das ist
meistens dann der Hausbesitzer. Und es ist
ein sehr komplexes Konstrukt, was eben
auch gesellschaftlich teilweise tief
verankert ist. Und da sprechen wir über
Rassismus, da sprechen wir über
wirklich ungleiche Verhältnisse in den jeweiligen
Gesellschaften. Und das ist
ein Riesenproblem. Politisch kann man
das angehen, aber es ist eben
nicht ausreichend. Und deswegen gibt
es natürlich große, gravierende
Probleme in der Umsetzung. Ich glaube aber dennoch,
dass der politische- die politischen
Reformen oder zumindest
die Gesetzesänderungen dazu geführt
haben, aufgrund des Drucks, dass man nicht
nur in Katar, sondern in der gesamten
Region ganz anders über Kafala und über
Bürgschaft und über Migration spricht.
Du kennst dich in der Region relativ gut aus,
auch aus beruflichen Gründen. Du
kennst dich auch sehr gut aus, du warst ja
sehr oft da. Kannst du das nicht
nachvollziehen, was er sagt? Das zarte
Pflänzchen, was da gerade in Teilen
am Wachsen ist, auch in den letzten zehn
Jahren, durch den öffentlichen
Druck. Ist das nicht nachvollziehbar für dich?
Das ist auf der einen Seite
nachvollziehbar, aber auf der anderen
-Seite muss man da-
-Aber du gehst nicht nach vorne, so
-nachvollziehbar ist es dann auch nicht.
-So nachvollziehbar ist es nicht und ich
werd dir auch sagen, warum es für mich
nicht so nachvollziehbar ist, nämlich
weil hinter dieser Öffnung aus meiner
Sicht eine ganz klare Strategie steht,
nämlich die Strategie, dass die Ressourcen
in diesen Ländern irgendwann mal zu Ende
gehen werden und die Königshäuser
ganz klar wissen, wir müssen uns dem Westen
öffnen, weil dort sind unsere- dort
sind neue Investitionsmöglichkeiten. Aber
was ist mit der Pressefreiheit?
Was ist mit der Meinungsfreiheit? Was ist
mit der Freiheit für Homosexuelle?
Da tun sie sich sehr, sehr schwer. Sobald
es um das Finanzielle geht, da sind
sie sofort vorne mit dabei. Aber
wenn wir zum Beispiel an den Fall
von Jamal Khashoggi denken oder andere
Beispiele, dort verharren sie meiner
Meinung nach in ihren Traditionen
-und wollen sich eben nicht öffnen.
-Jetzt könnte man natürlich argumentieren,
es könnte alles viel besser sein. Aber
Felicia, wäre es vielleicht ohne diese WM
-in Katar alles viel schlimmer?
-Ja klar. Wenn wir jetzt hier diese WM
nicht hätten und wir jetzt alle auch heute
nicht darüber sprechen würden, dann würde
es diesen Spotlight nicht geben.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht von der Hand
zu weisen, inwieweit das Auswirkungen
wirklich vor Ort jetzt hat,
die auch nachhaltig positiv sind für die Menschen,
weil das geht doch immer,
auch mal die Ohnmächtigen zu ermächtigen.
Und ich habe da halt einfach- da sehe
ich irgendwie die Löhner, die im Monat
250 Euro bekommen oder die oft auch nichts
bekommen, Hashtag Lohndiebstahl,
der ja da auch einfach gang und gäbe ist,
weil es da keine Handhabe gibt,
weil die Gesetze nicht angewandt werden.
Und im Gegensatz dazu diese Milliarden
Gelder, die da ausgegeben werden,
Stadien werden gebaut, wo man gar
nicht weiß, nachhaltig sind die auch nicht,
da wird 40 Grad auf 25 runter
gedreht. Das sind alles so Dinge, die ich einfach
unvereinbar finde und auch für die Spieler,
die da hinkommen. Die ganzen
Menschen, ich unterstelle denen gar
nichts böses, aber das ist doch einfach pervers.
Also ich kann da nicht anders als menschlich
zu argumentieren, mir ist schon
-klar, dass ich-
-Da kriegst du auch ganz viel Applaus. Da
wird jeder dir applaudieren
in Deutschland. Ja, danke schön.
-In Westeuropa. Du nicht. Außer Ronny.
-Ja, außer Ronny, das ist jetzt betrüblich.
Ich bin ja hier, um dich zu überzeugen,
euch zu überzeugen.
Du hast keine Verantwortung, du musst
dich niemandem rechtfertigen. Es ist klar,
dass jeder das gut findet. Aber in Katar
zum Beispiel, auch in anderen Regionen
der Welt, haben die ein sehr sensibles
Sensorium, wie wir sie dort beurteilen.
Zwar in Russland, auch so, in Brasilien
und in Katar führt das sogar dazu,
dass sich viele trotzig noch
mehr zurückziehen, weil die sind extrem,
ja schockiert darüber seit zehn
Jahren, wie dort die Kritik auf sie einprasselt.
Es gibt konservative Kreise, die die WM
am liebsten zurückgeben würden. Also
wir verlangen vom Fußball etwas, was wir ja
von den großen Konzernchefs anscheinend
nicht erwartet, die dafür größere
Profite machen. Warum nicht was kleineres?
Unsere Fußballclubs Schalke, Bayern
München, Borussia Dortmund. Niemand hat
ein ernstzunehmendes
Menschenrechtskonzept, niemand schaut
auf welche Sponsoren, auf welche
Trainingslager lassen wir uns ein.
Niemand hat bei einem
dreistelligen Millionen Etat eine ernstzunehmende
Abteilung, die diese Themen angeht.
Und wir hauen auf Katar drauf, haben aber
bei uns noch nicht mal die Hausaufgaben
gemacht. Und warum nicht was kleineres?
Warum nicht hinfahren, Interesse
entgegenbringen, kleinere Projekte,
Broschüren, Workshops, Konferenzen,
Wandel durch Annäherung. Ich weiß, es würdet
ihr wahrscheinlich auch für unrealistisch
halten, aber es gibt überhaupt nicht
die Debatte darüber. Es gibt nicht mal
Ansätze darüber. Und deswegen glaube ich,
dass diese Kritik vielleicht die wenigen
progressiven, fortschrittlichen,
kreativen Kräfte in Katar, die es gibt,
weniger als in Russland, weniger
als in Brasilien, viel weniger. Aber
das führt dazu, dass man die wenigen noch
weiter von sich wegschiebt. Hubi und Co.
sage ich mal, für die ist jetzt einfach
eine rote Linie erreicht. Es gab
jetzt verschiedene Beispiele
von Menschenrechtsverletzungen, von autokratischen
Strukturen und so weiter,
von Königshäusern, die offenbar
nicht wandelbar sein wollen. So ist zumindest
die Aussage gewesen. Kurze Frage an euch
Was glaubt ihr? Gibt es eine rote Linie?
Kann man Sport und Politik trennen?
Wo wäre für euch eine rote Linie? Schreibt
es uns gerne in die Kommentare und jetzt
darf Neven noch mal sprechen, weil du bist
ja auch schon länger nicht zu Wort
gekommen. Lass uns doch mal über
realistische Möglichkeiten reden.
Für wie realistisch hältst du es denn,
dass ein Mitte zwanzig Järhiger,
nehmen wir Joshua Kimmich! Warum denn jetzt
gerade den? Fällt mir gerade kein
anderer ein. Also der würde sich hinstellen
und sagen Ich fahr nicht mit. Ist
das denkbar? Ist das überhaupt denkbar?
Traut man sich das als aktiver
Profi? Ja, es ist ein sehr schwieriges Schuh.
Ich hätte sehr viel Respekt für ihn,
wenn er das tut. Die Tatsache ist, ich habe
jetzt eine Stiftung seit knapp zehn
Jahren im Fußballgeschäft, muss sich jedes Mal
durch eine neue Hürde durch. Allein
weil ich mich irgendwie politisch äußere
oder weil ich noch neben meinem
professionellen Fußball-Beruf noch mich
professionell mit Gemeinwesen
auseinandersetze. Was heißt, Hürde?
Die Hürde ist: Immer, wenn was schief
läuft, ist es, weil ich etwas anderes noch
mache. Also wenn ich einen Fehler
mache, wird er auf die Stiftung zurückgeführt.
Wenn ein anderer Spieler genau den gleichen
Fehler macht. Ja, ist ja normal,
nur menschlich. Man hat irgendwas, wo man
sagen kann: Weißt du was, wir zahlen ja,
damit du Fußball spielst und in Anführungsstrichen
auch die Fresse hältst.
Ja, tu das. Und wenn du es kritisierst,
dann gerne irgendwie mit irgendeiner
Symbolgestik, die nichts kostet
und wahrscheinlich nichts bewirkt,
sondern eigentlich genau das falsche
Signal an die Gesellschaft ist. Okay,
aber du hältst es für relativ
unwahrscheinlich, dass sich ein aktiver
Profi aus Protest in die Öffentlichkeit
stellt und sagt: Ich fahre nicht
mit zur WM. Richtig? Hab ich richtig
verstanden? Ja! Ich finde,dass- Das liegt
wiederum am System, an Druck. Das liegt
an den Interessen und am Druck. Es ist
eine Power Dynamik, in der die Vereine
vor allem entscheiden. Und wahrscheinlich,
wenn jemand sich dagegen
entscheiden würde, wäre es nicht nur schlecht
für die Person in der Nationalmannschaft,
sondern wahrscheinlich würden die Vereine
oder der Verein, bei dem der jeweilige
Spieler auch da ist, sehr schnell
eine Konsequenz daraus ziehen.
Die symbolische Aktion jetzt, also
diese Regenbogen Aktion, ist- also
der Fußball ist so politisch wie nie zuvor.
Wir sollten uns dafür kritisieren,
dass wir den Fußball Markt so haben wachsen
lassen, dass jemand wie Katar in Erscheinung
tritt. Da kann man die FIFA
kritisieren, da kann man die großen
globalen Fußball-Marken Bayern München,
Barcelona, Real Madrid
kritisieren, die wir mit unseren Trikots Käufen,
unseren Pay-TV Abos groß gemacht
haben. Aber daran liegt bei uns auch eine große
Schuld, weil wir diesen Markt
eben auch füttern, mit unserem Interesse,
mit unserer Nachfrage. Aber- Und deswegen sollten
wir da jetzt alle ganz normal
die WM spielen, oder wie? Also ich meine die Menschenrechte
werden ja trotzdem
verletzt. Das was du kannst, du
kannst deinen Verein, deinen Club könntest du
zum Beispiel boykottieren, weil der ein Teil
des Systems ist. Du könntest
mein Trikot nicht kaufen. Du
könntest vielleicht- Ich kauf keine Trikots,
weil er Gazprom draufsteht. Das ist
genau dasselbe. Das ist ja schon mal ein guter
Schritt. Dann könntest du deine Freunde.
Du könntest deine Abgeordneten
im Wahlkreis für das Thema
interessieren. Du könntest offenen Brief schreiben,
du könntest eine Kampagne starten. Du
bist ein überdurchschnittlich engagierter Fan,
das weiß ich. Aber wir müssen uns
vor Augen führen, wir sind eine kritische
Minderheit und die Fußball Blase
platzt auch nicht. Da werden Millionen
und Abermillionen Menschen wieder
diese WM schauen, weil Fernsehsender,
weil Nachrichtenportale, weil Sponsoren,
weil alle davon profitieren.
Und deswegen haben wir als Konsumenten
eine Macht, die wir noch zu unreichend
nutzen. So Benjamin. Jetzt gab es ja
so viele Vorschläge: Abgeordnete,
keine Trikots kaufen, mehr Dialog,
Wandel durch Annäherung. Du bist trotzdem noch
keinen Schritt nach vorne gegangen.
Was muss denn passieren, damit du überzeugt
-bist?
-Ich würde mir wünschen, dass die
katarische Regierung konsequent
diese Gesetze, die dazu da sind, Menschen
zu schützen, die Arbeitsrechte zu schützen,
dass die konsequent durchgesetzt
werden, dass Unternehmen, die dagegen
verstoßen, bestraft werden. Das ist
aus meiner Sicht die Kraft und die Power,
die diese Regierung hat. Ein Zeichen,
was sie setzen könnten. Da geht es nicht
um Annäherung oder das Fußball System
zu ändern oder sonst irgendwas. Da geht
es um eine klare Strategie, um eine Handlung
und das hat leider in den letzten
zehn Jahren nicht stattgefunden. Und solange
das nicht
stattfindet, bleibe ich hier stehen.
Okay, lasst uns doch jetzt
eine Art Kompromissrunde reingehen,
dass wir am Ende noch mal ganz
kurz versuchen, noch mehr Menschen mehr
in die Mitte zu kriegen. Ich mache
einen Vorschlag. Danach macht jede Gruppe
von euch einen Vorschlag. Und dann
schauen wir mal, ob wir noch weiter
auseinandergehen oder vielleicht
doch ein bisschen näher zusammenkommen.
Mein Vorschlag ist einer, darüber
haben wir noch gar nicht so viel geredet.
Welche Rolle nämlich, wenn wir Sport
und Politik denken, welche Rolle die Politik
spielen könnte? Jetzt ist ja auch gerade
China und Olympia in der Debatte. Da gibt
es einige Staaten, die sagen: Aus Protest
schicken wir nicht unsere großen Minister
oder Staatschefs dahin, sondern wir schicken,
wenn überhaupt, nur kleinere
Diplomaten. Und ich dachte mir,
das könnten wir doch für Katar vielleicht
auch machen. Das heißt, sagen wir, wir suchen
einen kleinsten gemeinsamen Nenner
erstmal. Könnt ihr der Forderung
zustimmen, die würde dann
auch in die Bundesregierung gehen, ja,
wir schicken die Nationalelf hin, aber nein,
wir schicken nicht den neuen
Bundeskanzler hin. Also wir adeln das Ganze nicht,
indem wir am Ende Olaf Scholz
zusammen mit dem König im Stadion sitzen haben,
sondern sagen: Öffentliche
Repräsentanten gehen nicht dahin, aber die Nationalelf
schon. Wenn ihr sagt: Das kann ich mir
voll- Das ist ein guter Vorschlag,
mal anders gedacht. Nationalelf ja,
aber Regierung nicht. Dann könnt ihr Schritt
nach vorne gehen. Und wenn ihr sagt:
Nee, reicht mir nicht, dann bleibt ihr stehen
oder geht nach hinten. Ahja, drei
Leute. Warum? Warum findest du es nicht gut? Ja,
weil wer, wenn nicht ein hochrangiger
Politiker, kann da mal sagen: Leute,
ihr mit euren Arbeitsrechten und so
weiter. Also bitte, jetzt reicht's aber
auch mal! Also da kann man ja mal
informell auf der Tribüne oder was weiß
ich nachher noch mal sprechen, weil wenn da so
ein kleiner Diplomaten Johnny
ankommt, dann nimmt ja keiner ernst.
Naja gut, auf der Seite versuche ich dich ernst
zu nehmen und ein klares Zeichen zu setzen.
Also wenn der Bundeskanzler nicht
zum WM-Endspiel fährt, Deutschland
gegen England und der Bundeskanzler sagt: Nee,
ich komme aber nicht. Das wäre schon
klar- Ja, wenn der Bundeskanzler da hinfährt
und quasi gute Miene zum bösen Spiel
macht und sich da hofieren lässt und sagt: Alles
super! Dann sollte er da nicht
hinfahren, dann sollte er besser seine Haltung zeigen
und der ganzen Veranstaltung
fernbleiben. Wenn er aber sich vornimmt, da irgendwie
mal auf den Tisch zu hauen, in Anführungsstrichen
oder den Finger
in die Wunde zu legen und ein bisschen
den Druck aufrechtzuerhalten, dann ist das ja
dann dort die Chance. Aber es geht
hier um Kompromisse. Deswegen finde ich,
dass es ein ein guter Kompromiss ist.
Wir haben fast jetzt schon Rollen getauscht,
weil das ist eigentlich
auch meine Haltung. Trotzdem würde
ich von dieser Haltung ein bisschen
abrücken und es macht nur Sinn, wenn Olaf
Scholz oder andere
Regierungsmitglieder dort nicht hin reisen,
wenn sie auch darüber hinaus einen
kritischeren Ton anschlagen. Sie müssen
das unterfüttern. Wenn sie aber
immer wieder, wenn mal wieder der große
Autobauer ein bisschen Geld braucht
oder die eine Deutsche Bank oder sonst-
Und wenn die Aufmerksamkeit weg
ist, dann wird es weitergehen. Daran glaube
ich nicht so richtig. Ich finde es aber
trotzdem- Es ist ein für alle Seiten
gesichtswahrender Kompromiss, würde
ich sagen. Ich würde euch jetzt bitten: Merkt
euch eure Position. Steckt mal ein bisschen
die Köpfe coronagerecht zusammen
und überlegt euch irgendeine These,
einen Satz, den ihr gleich vortragen könntet.
So. Das ist mit Sicherheit, wenn wir einen
Vorschlag bringen können- Aber was ist
denn was Konkretes? Aber es ist
genauso wie die deutsche Nationalmannschaft-
Die Gruppen sind also gerade in der Kompromissfindung.
Was wäre denn
euer Vorschlag? Welcher Kompromisslinie
würdet ihr zeichnen? Also wie kriegen
wir diese beiden Gruppen noch
enger zusammen? In der Frage: Boykott, ja
oder nein? Gibt es einen Mittelweg?
Schreibt's mir gerne in die Kommentare.
Und das ist ja das Problem, dass wir immer
denken bis zur WM und ein Jahr danach ist
uns alles wieder egal. Wunderbar! Habt
ihr irgendetwas euch überlegt? Fangt ihr an!
Wir haben uns überlegt, dass es Sinn
machen würde, wenn wir ganz, ganz viele
unterschiedliche Akteure zu einem
Dialog zusammenbringen, und zwar aus Katar,
aus Europa, auch aus den Entsendestaaten
der Migranten, aus Bangladesh und anderen,
um zum Beispiel ein Drei-Länder-Turnier
durchzuführen, das Ganze zu begleiten,
mit Veranstaltungen, mit Diskussionsforen,
um über diese Probleme der Migration
aufmerksam zu machen. Das ist
kein Problem, das nur Katar betrifft.
Sondern es ist ein Problem, was die gesamte
Welt nach Katar betreffen wird
und hier einfach diesen Austausch
zu schaffen, damit am Ende
auch Menschenrechte und Arbeitsschutzrechte
eine Benchmark werden.
Auch für Länder wie Katar. Damit
sie einfach nicht mehr darum herumkommen,
weil der Druck so groß ist, dass sie sonst
eben hinten runterfallen würden
in der öffentlichen
Berichterstattung. Daher glauben wir, dass eine solche
Veranstaltung oder mehrere
Veranstaltungen, die eben unterschiedliche
Gruppen zusammenbringen, hier sehr gut
helfen könnte. Stimmt ihr dem zu? Geht
den Schritt nach vorne, dann dürft
ihr es jetzt tun. Und wenn ihr Zweifel habt,
könnt ihr sie gerne begründen. Also es ist
auf jeden Fall eine super Sache. Hat Hand
und Fuß. Gut vorgetragen. Top. So
ein Dialog ist ja auf jeden Fall wichtig
und anlassbezogen das zu machen ist
natürlich was, das hat mit der WM jetzt
erst mal gar nichts mehr zu tun,
sondern man macht extra noch mal ein Angebot dazu.
Deswegen finde ich das gut, weil es konkret
ist, inwiefern man da die Leute
wirklich dazu kriegt, also zu kommen
oder sich auch kritische Sachen anzuhören
von katarischer Seite oder von denen,
die von diesen Machtstrukturen profitieren,
das lasse ich mal dahingestellt.
Aber so zwecks Aufklärung und nicht
nur schwarz-weiß Denken ist glaube
ich eine schlaue Sache. Und auch vielleicht
Sinn der Sache ist ja, dass alle
Akteure mit da reinkommen und sich engagieren
und das ist auch jetzt vielleicht nach der WM
erst mal stattfinden würde, weil es so
wichtig ist. Genau das wir nicht zu dem Punkt
kommen: WM ist vorbei, nächste EM,
nächste WM und die Aufmerksamkeit
ist komplett weg, sondern auch tatsächlich
gucken: Ja, was ist danach noch
realisiert worden? Und da sozusagen am Ball bleiben.
Um eben nicht immer da zu stehen,
zu sagen: Das ist alles doof
da mit dem System und den Ländern,
aber wir gucken es trotzdem. Also mal
ein bisschen ins Handeln zu kommen.
Okay, das war der Vorschlag. Habt ihr auch einen
-Vorschlag?
-Unser Vorschlag ist eigentlich ein ganz
konkretes Beispiel. Es gibt schon
etwas, nämlich der dänische Fußballverband hat
sich dazu durchgerungen,
dass keine Sponsoren-Tafeln
während dieser Weltmeisterschaft
im Trainingslager, im Hotel zu sehen
sein werden, sondern stattdessen
Botschaften pro Menschenrechte
mit Zustimmung der Sponsoren. Es heißt
also: Die verzichten auf Geld,
sie verzichten auf diese große
Bühne, das größte Sportereignis, was es gibt.
Und dort gibt es ein konkretes
Beispiel, was ich finde, was alle Verbände
-übernehmen sollten.
-Ihr seid alle nach vorne gegangen. Das
kann ich nur begrüßen. Absolut. Ich bin
nicht für mehr Sponsoren und noch mehr
Glitzer. So ein Statement kann ja
auch positiv- Also das finde ich, so
eine zeitgemäße
Gesellschaftspolitik im Fußball schließt Sponsoren ein.
Indem sie wegbleiben, können sie damit
sogar Geld verdienen, indem sie ihr Image
weiterhin schärfen und Profil
gewinnen. Und das finde ich aber legitim,
weil es ist eine kommerzialisierte
Branche, es ist ein Wirtschaftszweig
und ich finde die Clubs sollten
noch mehr auf progressive Sponsoren,
Unternehmen zugehen, die vielleicht
mit solchen Menschenrechtsbotschaften dann
auch Zielgruppen und noch mehr Geld
verdienen. Deswegen ist Dänemark ein gutes
Beispiel. Hubi! Ja, ich wollte nur noch
mal kritisch da ergänzen, dass das ja
auch die Gefahr birgt, dass so
Unternehmen sich reinwaschen. Also bei Black Lives
Matter haben wir es gesehen, das ist
ja auch das als Marketing und als Werbetool
dann benutzt wird, dass Politik schnell
zu Werbung führt, weil es halt gerade woke
ist und ich war nicht so
hundertprozentig überzeugt. Also gute Idee, kann man
machen. Ich war da nicht so ganz
überzeugt von diesem, so weil ich mir denke, es ist
genauso wie diese FIFA und UEFA
Banner, die überall hängen. Da steht da ein guter
Spruch. Und am Ende- Aber vielleicht
noch ein Satz dazu. Ich meine, kombiniert
mit dem Vorschlag, den wir gemacht
haben, wäre das ja tatsächlich ein Ansatz, wo man
beides zusammenbringen könnte, weil man
auch dann der Gefahr entgegen beugen
würde, dass es eben reines
Marketing ist. Und von daher glaube ich, ist ja
vielleicht die Kombination aus den beiden,
was wir gemacht haben, ein Ansatz.
Ich fand es sehr bereichernd,
weil wir einerseits auch uns inhaltlich
ausgetauscht haben, neue
Perspektiven da reingekommen sind, auch zueinander
gekommen sind, aber dann auch wieder
uns entfernt haben. Insgesamt sehr dynamisch
und so habe ich mir auch erhofft.
Wie fandest du es?
Also ich fand das auch sehr wertschätzend.
Ich habe mich auch über eine Perspektive
wie deine sehr gefreut, weil die natürlich
sehr exklusiv auch ist. Also keiner
von uns hat die Erfahrung, selbst
als Spieler da auch vielleicht in die Rolle
reinzukommen, Entscheidungen zu treffen.
Und deswegen bin ich sehr dankbar, dass du
-mich da auch persönlich bereichert hast.
-Ich habe schon noch die Hoffnung, dass
vielleicht ein einzelner Spieler oder ein wichtiger
Funktionär oder ein ehemaliger,
was weiß ich David Beckham,
Zinédine Zidane, in der Größenordnung,
dass sie sagen: Ich fahr da nicht hin
und ich gucke mir das nicht an. Und ich rede
aber darüber und trete Informaten auf,
die sich kritisch mit Katar auseinandersetzen.
Also, dass man schon nicht glauben
muss, dass Boykott und fehlende Aufmerksamkeit
gleich sind, sondern es kann
sich ergänzen. Ja, würde ich zustimmen.
Ich finde es schade, dass so
wie wir diskutiert haben, kritisch,
trotzdem wertschätzen, das hätten wir viel
früher machen sollen. Also die WM wurde ja
vor elf Jahren vergeben. Es ist sehr,
sehr lange her und das Narrativ ist gesetzt.
Und es wäre schön gewesen, wenn wir früher
auf die Idee gekommen wären. Also
wir haben gesehen, wenn man
Kompromisse sucht oder Lösungsvorschläge sucht,
kann man auch welche finden. Ihr seid
alle relativ nahe zusammengekommen. Ich habe
das Gefühl, wenn man diese ganzen
Vorschläge jetzt kombiniert, dann würdet
ihr vielleicht sogar noch weiter im inneren
Feld stehen. Aber ich will euch
jetzt da nicht hin drängen. Ja,
liebe Politik, lieber DFB, liebe Sponsoren,
wir haben hier ein paar
Vorschläge gemacht. Bitte achtet sehr darauf,
wie er mit euren
Regierungsvertreter*innen umgeht in Katar. Bitte nehmt
diesen Vorschlag ernst. Gründet
ein Netzwerk mit allen zusammen, um einen
nachhaltigen Dialog über die WM
hinaus zu etablieren. Und vielleicht,
liebe Sponsoren und lieber DFB,
könnt ihr euch bei den Dänen tatsächlich
ein Beispiel nehmen? VW, Grüße.
Hier liegt einiges auf dem Tisch. Wir haben
den Eindruck, das könnte eventuell
weiterhelfen. Und die nächste Folge heißt
dann FIFA zerschlagen, ja oder nein?
In diesem Sinne ganz herzlichen Dank, Merci!
Danke! Vollkommen klar, alle
Beteiligten heute sind natürlich
gegen Menschenrechtsverletzungen.
Die große Frage wird sein: Wie gehen
wir am besten gegen sie vor? Und ich glaube,
ein weiteres Thema ist heute
auch noch deutlich geworden,
nämlich dass der Profifußball an sich mal
auf den Prüfstand gestellt werden
sollte. Das betrifft auch den DFB und vor allem
die FIFA. Wenn ihr 13 Fragen nicht
so schlecht findet, dann abonniert doch
einfach unseren Kanal. Das könnt ihr hier
tun. Und eine weitere Folge 13 Fragen
findet ihr hier oben und hier gibt es ein
weiteres Video zum Thema.